china se enfrenta a un rebrote de
positivos en kobe 19 tras meses y aunque
el número de casos sigue relativamente
bajo y sólo se han registrado dos
muertes en la última oleada muchos de
los positivos lo son en la su variante
de omicron de punto 2 altamente
contagiosa no obstante los expertos del
país se muestran optimistas
aunque recientemente hay un
resurgimiento de los casos en china e
incluso hay rebrotes en algunas regiones
no ha habido un crecimiento exponencial
porque estamos tomando una serie de
medidas eficientes para contener su
desarrollo como china y los seguidores
de unas medidas que el gobierno de
chirín pink ha pedido que no interfieran
con los medios de subsistencia de los
chinos y es que la economía del gigante
asiático se ha visto fuertemente
afectada por la pandemia muchas fábricas
han suspendido su operación y el tráfico
de camiones se ha ralentizado afectando
negativamente a la cadena de suministros
y las medidas también han afectado la
vida cotidiana de millones de personas
nuestra escuela ha suspendido las clases
y ahora sólo hay online ahora nos
haremos pruebas de kobe 19 porque acaba
de salir un nuevo aviso no obstante la
mayoría de la población está a favor de
las medidas y muchos han quedado
impactados con la situación de hong kong
que este mes sobrepasó su capacidad
hospitalaria y funeraria más del 87 por
ciento de la población china está
completamente vacunado aún así el
gobierno ha asegurado que va a desplegar
una campaña masiva de refuerzo de las
vacunas